-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here, you made it.
You're watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, guys,
some fun holiday news --
Mariah Carey just announced
that, this December,
she's playing a Christmas show
at Madison Square Garden.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mariah Carey Christmas show
in New York City.
When they heard that,
The Rockettes were like,
"Stay in your lane, girl!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Stay in your lane!"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-So, if you want to hear "All
I Want for Christmas is You,"
you can either go to the concert
or any CVS
from now until January.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Some other New York news --
yesterday, Senator Ted Cruz
was on "The View,"
and he got heckled and cursed at
by some people in the audience.
[ Cheers ]
Don't worry --
after a few minutes,
security was able to remove
Joy and Whoopi from the set,
and so then...
[ Laughter ]
Some of the hecklers
were climate activists.
The rest were a group of moms
who were mad that Ted Cruz
was the guest they were seeing
on "The View."
It's like, "Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
Some news from Washington --
today, President Biden
got the updated
COVID booster shot
and encouraged Americans
to do the same.
That's right -- a 79-year-old
getting a shot on TV.
You know how excited
everyone was for Taylor Swift's
album to drop?
This wasn't like that.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, this was Biden's
fifth COVID shot.
Most Americans are like,
"I'm just gonna wait
till they all come out
and binge 'em all at once."
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw this today --
Bob Woodward released
an audiobook of his
20 interviews
with former president Trump,
called "The Trump Tapes."
And I didn't know this,
but apparently, at one point,
Woodward asked Trump
some rapid-fire questions.
Have you heard of this?
-Really?
-Yeah, it's fascinating.
Take a listen to this.
-Yeah, just very interesting.
Rapid-fire questions.
-Wow.
-Pillsbury Doughboy.
-Wow!
-Guys, this is very exciting.
We're only six days away
from Halloween.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I heard that some of this
year's most popular costumes
are Spider-Man,
the "Stranger Things" kids,
and dinosaurs, while the least
popular is antisemitic guy.
And, uh...
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Least popular.
The least popular costume.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Everyone
is talking about this --
today, after weeks of public
pressure, Adidas finally ended
their partnership
with Kanye West
due to his antisemitic remarks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think we finally
answered the question,
"Is there such a thing
as bad publicity?"
Yes, I think there is.
Yep, Kanye has now lost
his deals with Adidas,
Balenciaga, and Manischewitz.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey!
-And now Gap also announced
that they're pulling all Yeezy
products from their stores.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yep.
Meanwhile, TJ Maxx is like,
"We'll sell whatever you got."
[ Laughter ]
"We let it rip in this place."
Some more business news,
the Federal Trade Commission
wants to hold the CEO of
alcohol delivery service Drizly
accountable for
a 2020 data breach.
In response,
Drizly released this statement.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay. All right.
Well, get this -- I read that
Apple is now selling a door lock
for your house that you can
unlock with an iPhone.
Yep, so in case
you lose your iPhone,
make sure to keep a spare one
under the mat.
[ Laughter ]
Breaking into someone's home
is about to be super easy.
Just stand on the porch and yell
"Siri, unlock house!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, a new report says
that, since the pandemic,
people have gotten worse
at interacting with each other.
I don't think that's true.
Do you agree with that, Tariq?
-Good.
[ Laughter ]
-Off to a bad start.
Higgins, how you been?
-Thanks, you too.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, 0 for 2.
One last try.
Let's go with Mike,
the camera guy.
How you doing?
-I'm well, Jimmy.
Thanks for asking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
Finally, a normal response.
Well, this is wild.
Due to a broken elevator,
five tourists were stuck
in a Grand Canyon hotel
for over a day,
200 feet underground.
Yep, the only person
in a deeper hole is Kanye West.
Yeah, that's right.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, finally --
[ Applause ]
It is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-All right.
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five
different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
I can see everyone just looking
at each other, confused.
But they should be there,
somewhere.
You can vote for all of them,
if you want.
You can vote for none of them,
Whatever you want, we'd like to
see the results here, live.
This is real.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too?
-Got my clicker.
-Yep, good.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
live, on the show, so you all
can like it and "wetweet" it.
[ Audience "Ahhs" ]
Yeah, it's a shared experience.
All right,
you guys ready for this?
-Yeah!
-All right.
The first tweet is...
All right.
-Wow.
-Starting off slow.
I'm gonna say yes for that, just
'cause it's starting off slow.
But I -- I understand that one.
-Yeah.
-You wear the costume,
and then you ask --
You get it, and then --
-"Get it? Get what it is?"
-"Do you get it?"
-Yeah.
-I understood.
The votes are in.
They were in almost immediately,
I could tell.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see the results here.
Yeah, all right.
That's not bad.
All right, 122 said,
"No, thanks."
All right, that's fine.
All right.
How about this next one?
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
So, are...
Hm, I don't know about that one.
-Yeah, Rice Krispies?
-I don't know about that one.
I would have said,
"Snap, Crackle, and Pop
are a throuple, fight me."
[ Light laughter ]
-I'd say -- I'd say, "Snap,
Crackle, and Pop are a throuple.
Don't @ me."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah. Right.
-[ Laughs ] All right.
I don't know about
that one, either.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Oh, all right,
it's getting up there.
People are warming up.
-Yeah.
-To the idea --
-A little bit, they're going --
-They're warming up to the idea
and seeing that this is real,
in real time.
-Yeah. They're not used
to pressing buttons.
-These are big decisions.
-Yeah.
-'Cause one of these
could be tweeted --
-It's up to them. It's up to
you guys which one goes out.
-All right.
You ready for this next one?
-Snap, Crackle, Pop, man.
-All right, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there you go.
You warmed 'em up.
-Yeah, warmed 'em up
a little bit.
I'm still not at -- not that
many people laughed.
-I think this one's going to be
the highest one.
-You think that one's getting --
the highest, do you think?
-The highest one so far.
-Yeah.
-Tariq, you think so?
All right, yeah.
I think it's up there.
What are you thinking?
Like, did we break
a hundred on this one?
-I think we might break --
Yeah, 101, I'm gonna say.
Or 98.
-What are you thinking?
-I'm gonna say 104.
-Quest?
[ Drumroll ]
-113.
-I'm gonna say 120.
-120, wow.
-Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Wow, I didn't even know --
-It wasn't that good.
-That wasn't that good at all.
No, they're being very nice.
All right.
Next up, how about this one?
Here, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
Come on, that's a biggie.
-Yeah, it's a lot to do.
-Come on.
-It's a lot to chew on,
but it's worth it.
-It's worth the ride, yeah.
♪♪
-You -- He got you on that one?
-I like that one.
-Yeah, I like that one, too.
All right, I think
that one's up there, too.
-I think it's up there.
But the last one was high.
-That was maybe
artificially high.
-Yeah.
Let's see the results
on this one.
-Oh!
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good, good,
but still not "per se."
-Not as high, yeah.
-"Per se" is the one, yeah.
We have one last one here.
This last one is...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
-Come on.
You've got to beat 188.
-I think this is gonna --
-Come on.
That's the winner, people.
Come on.
-People are still laughing.
So, this one feels good.
-Yeah, come on.
Click yes.
-Go ahead, give a wave.
You're allowed to wave.
Go for it, yeah.
Can we get some shots
of the audience?
Yeah, give a good wave.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think this one --
-I think --
-This one might be
the closest to 100%.
-I would hope so.
-Audience enjoyed this one.
I think so.
Let's see the results.
Yeah!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
That's a history-making tweet,
right there.
History!
Thank you!
The winner is number five.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it
a "wetweet," and enjoy.
We have a great show.